in other news that leaves two Americans
are among more than 150 people that are
killed in a crush in Seoul South Korea
over the weekend now thousands of people
had gathered in a nightclub in the
district of the Korean capital to
celebrate Halloween is still unclear
what exactly started this deadly crush
the dozens of upcoming large events
around the country have now been
canceled Elizabeth Palmer has more and
we have to tell you that some of these
images are very disturbing
Koreans today were paying their respects
and still trying to observe the scale of
this tragedy which started out as a
Halloween celebration on Saturday night
thousands of mostly young people finally
freed from coveted restrictions flooded
into the narrow streets of seoul's
nightlife District
crowd
girl crush on the Halloween party turned
into a horror show
rescue workers arrived just 10 minutes
after the first SOS call but had trouble
pulling people free Korean television
broadcast pictures of Medics doing CPR
in the road
Janelle's story was in the crowd this
was Next Level shoulder to shoulder
front to back just shimmying along on
those streets oh no control about where
you're going to move that time based on
where the crowd pushes you and she said
there was no way to see what was going
on there was Panic coming towards us
some shouts of fear but also confusion
we didn't know really what was happening
to us it became horribly clear when body
after body was wheeled out to waiting
ambulances most of the victims were in
their twenties including two American
students Angie ski from the University
of Kentucky and Stephen blessey from
Georgia's Kennesaw State
their families along with dozens more
across Korea are reeling with grief
after receiving news no parent should
ever have to hear
Elizabeth Palmer CBS News Tokyo